let's see if we can simplify five times
the square root of 117 117 so 117
doesn't jump out at me is some type of a
perfect square so let's actually take
its prime factorization and see if any
of those prime factorizations any of
those prime factors show up more than
once so it's clearly it's a it's an odd
number it's clearly not divisible by two
to test whether it's divisible by three
we can add up all of the digits and we
explain why this works in it in another
place on Khan Academy but if you add up
all the digits you've got a nine and
nine is divisible by 3 so 117 is going
to be divisible by three now let's do a
little aside here and figure out what
117 divided by 3 actually is so three
goes in doesn't go into one it does go
into 11 3 times 3 times 3 is 9 subtract
you got a remainder of 2 bring down a 7
3 times lioka 3 goes into 27 9 times 9
times 3 is 27
subtract and you're done it goes in
perfectly and so this so we can factor
117 as 3 times 39 now 39 we can factor
as that jumps out more at us that's
divisible by 3 that's equivalent to 3
times 13 and then all of these are now
prime numbers so we could say that this
thing is the same as 5 times the square
root the square root of 3 times 3 3
times 3 3 times 3 times 13 times 13 and
this is going to be the same thing as
and we know this from our exponent
properties as 5 times the square root of
3 times 3 5 times the square root of 3
times 3 times the square root times the
square root of 13
now what's the square root of 3 times 3
what's the square root of 9 that's the
square root of 3 squared any of those
well that's just going to give you 3 so
this is just going to simplify to 3 so
this whole thing is 5 times 3 times the
square root of 13 so this part right
over here
would give us 15
times the square-root times the square
root of 13 let's do one more example
here so let's try to simplify three
times the square root of 26 actually 26
in yellow like I did in the previous
problem 26 well 26 is clearly an even
number so it's going to be divisible by
2 we can rewrite it as 2 times 13 and
then we're done 13 is a prime number we
can't factor this anymore and so 26
doesn't have any perfect squares in it
it's not like we can factor it out as
the factor some other numbers and some
perfect squares like we did here 117 is
13 times 9 it's the product of a perfect
square and 13 26 isn't so we've
simplified this about as much as we can
we would just leave this as 3 times the
square root of 26